hello guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to another Sparky Engine dev vlog it has
been a really long time since the last
one I'm sure I don't need to say that
but uh but I've done some work since
then I haven't been working on Sparky
too much haven't had that much time but
the stuff that I did do recently I just
wanted to share with you guys
hence the dev vlog so I mean if we look
at the commits here the stuff that I'm
really gonna focus on is basically since
kind of eight days ago because before
that it was like a month I think without
any work really so there's two kind of
things that I'm working on right now I
know and also in this dev vlog we're
gonna cover at the end what's gonna
happen in the next few weeks in the next
few months because I had I do have a
Selleck plan but basically I've been
working on well I mean two big things
are kind of two big things have happened
the kind of the actually big one I would
say is a it's physics today right so
there's a physics 2d branch and it's
basically incorporating box 2d I'm sure
you could look at the comments for
example this is incorporating box 2d to
essentially like there's a physics
component now a physics 2d component
here it is Ryan you can see this is
using kind of box 2d to basically do
some stuff it's very much working
progress
I wouldn't like it's not even in master
yet at all none of the physics 2d kind
of stuff is but yeah I mean it's been
it's I've been kind of working on that
it's been pretty easy to implement to be
honest I mean box today is a really nice
library this seems to do everything
correctly the thing is I've been having
somewhat of why I've been having some
performance issues which I need to work
out but also the biggest thing that was
interesting about box today and well I
mean it was inevitable anyway because as
soon as you start kind of working on
physics you start having to I guess
reflect on your maths library right and
the fact is like in Sparky we had a very
loose definition of what rectangles were
and what a a B B's were so for example
rectangles and Sparkie used to be kind
of a bottom bottom-left kind of they
they used to essentially be a point plus
width and height so you would have like
a point
we're in like the bottom left corner of
like a rectangle and that would be a
coordinate being stored there that
that's what the rectangle coordinate was
the position of the rectangle and then
you had like a width and height right
but box2d kind of deals with a center
point and then half width and half
height extents right so after some after
some thinking I am I decided to go with
that as well so we'll we'll kind of look
at those changes kind of from from
beginning to end I guess I don't know if
I covered this stuff I don't think it's
to require I don't remember I mean just
loosely touching on that stuff scene 2d
was kind of new I don't know if that was
in the last devlog probably not though
and essentially what I'm doing kind of
right now with Vox today obviously is
I'm trying to get the engine to a more
or less kind of solid position as far as
2d goes because I'm sleeping and
focusing like most of the year was kind
of spent on and last year I guess as
well was spent on 3d stuff I'm like
physically based rendering and you know
getting a proper 3d render but I kind of
took a break from that now and I'm doing
some 2d stuff okay cool so anyway enough
talking let's look at what I've actually
done so fixed font atlases never being
marked clean after being updated this
was a huge change as in it was only
three lines or like one real line but
basically when I started doing the Box
today stuff I noticed that my
performance was absolutely terrible like
I was rendering like maybe ten or so
sprites and they were all being patched
together obviously and that was taking
like it was only running out like 150
FPS and I was like well that's something
has to be wrong like something has to be
very wrong because that's absolutely
ridiculous performance ridiculously low
so I did I've just literally just used
visual Studios profiling tools to figure
out what on earth was taking so long and
I realized this update atlas thing in
font was taking up about 80% of the time
and so it turns out that
like what I did was I there's this thing
called dirty in the freetype Atlas and
I'm pretty sure I actually added that I
don't think that's standard freetype
well standard for tile or anything but I
added that to basically make sure that
we could update our Alice's yeah that
would have been me and isn't into some
reason okay anyway whatever so if it is
dirty that's I didn't even realize it
was at the end and I'm setting the end
to false which is fun but anyway the
point is that's probably going to be a
compiler warning but basically what we
have here is we didn't have this line
and so the performance before I added
this line and this is in release mode by
the way but the performance was very
very bad
let's see if we can yeah I mean like
this right which is not really that much
stuff going on here at all was running
at about 150 fps about 5 to 6
milliseconds in the rendering right
adding this line takes our 5 to 6
milliseconds 150 fps all the way up to
its 0.4 milliseconds and about 1200 FPS
when I'm recording so there you go
right very easy change and it's as you
can see increase our performance by a
lot so the issue that was happening
there obviously is that when when extra
characters or when new characters were
being used the one that hadn't yet been
used in the font right so the way that
forms work roughly is essentially you
have a like a font I like a texture
Atlas right or a sprite sheet that
contains all of your glyphs that make up
you know your font so basically using
your font when you decide to draw a
string they'll go through each character
if the glyph doesn't already exist and
by glyph it just literally just mean
character right
if the cliff doesn't exist inside the
inside the the texture it will add the
glyph to the texture right using the
font and that's all good but obviously
you have to have some kind of cache
there like as in if the glyph is already
in the texture you don't need to update
the texture but what was happening here
is that obviously this code didn't
realize that it was
updating so every time like this dirty
was always true so update Atlas would
always you can see every time the
texture was requested it would update
the Atlas which would mean it would
actually you know set the daughter of
the texture and of course what that does
say for DirectX is it actually like he
know opens up a it actually maps the the
texture which is very slow so we don't
want to do that anymore and we're not
anymore thanks to this line but
basically that solves a bunch of
performance issues that I had with
Sparky that I was like what's good
actually going on here cuz this is a
slow okay the initial 2d work this is
again this was just I think an
auto-generated yeah this was basically
the merge that I did this doesn't
actually include any 2d physics stuff
this commit message was written
automatically by that shouldn't be in
there but anyway the commit message was
written automatically by KITT merging
okay the other big thing that I did
though I guess I mean one of the things
that I did is kind of big is we now have
a time step right and that was required
for box today and stuff so essentially a
time step is just a little struct that
we have here that essentially just gives
us it doesn't even have an
implementation file it just gives us the
time step right since the last frame
essentially and also I believe yeah okay
so won't give you time since the
beginning or anything but it will give
you the time since that since this is
the last frame right so because of that
the way that you can use it is it gets
passed on update right so every on
update method so say in like test today
or something has that time step right so
we could easily see for example what
hour elapsed get in milliseconds what
our milliseconds were since the last
frame right which so it should be like
well yeah 0.8 ish right
the thing is though this will not be
this will be like actually based on this
rather than facing or anything so you
can see it's kind of the same as that
right it should probably be more or less
stuck at about 16 because it should be
running on like 6
FPS but we'll investigate that of course
when it comes up to it
in fact that should be running at about
sixty I wonder why I guess this methods
getting hit more often huh interesting
anyway yeah okay I know why that's
happening still needs a little bit of
work but that suffice wasn't for box
today which is why I added it the other
stuff the other big stuff is the debug
the debug menu now supports directories
okay this took me a little bit of time
to implement a few hours quite a big job
but basically what you can do now with
your debug menu is saying like test 2d
or something I think I've actually yeah
what you can essentially do is when you
have something to to the debug menu you
can specify like a directory so like for
example you know if you were doing you
know I don't know renderer stuff another
folder my variable right and if we just
do a new float I really care but if
basically you can put stuff with slashes
in and what will happen is you'll see
that there is now folder or a directory
called renderer stuff right and in there
there's another folder and then here's
your variable which you can adjust right
so that's the way that that works and
then the the back button currently is
just this like extra kind of button up
top I might change the UI around just
haven't been bothered too much but you
can see stuff like the rendered like the
2d renderer unless you like to turn on
post effects and masks and stuff all in
here as well and then the debug menu
like you know you can just like
horizontal padding and stuff like that
vertical padding walnuts reduce that and
then like foam size and stuff so that's
quite fun yeah that should have actually
aligned that anyway the point is that we
have that stuff but yeah the the
directories is really useful because
obviously we can actually group stuff
that belongs in directories now I
believe test 3d as well actually has a
let's see test 3d will actually have
like its own folder because test three
like has a launcher has a lot of it has
a lot of stuff anyway at Con Thien
twelve today
but sorry I'm very tired so if this is a
bit incoherent then I apologize so you
can see that's like a little macro that
will essentially add everything to do
have menu under this test 3d directory
so for example this stuff it's a cube
light intensity all that stuff will just
be over here in under test 3d ryan and
then you can adjust the stuff there so
it's it's really nice because it group
stuff together and you can see it's
really easy to use api wise you just
specify like a path with slashes it's a
for example you can see the render a 2d
does that i don't even remember how i
made it work for the face but i guess
it's just in here right the only problem
is that some of these need to be global
because for example we have yeah so for
example here you can see we just got
render 2d / blah blah some of these need
to be static as well because like
there's a bunch of different batch 2d
render like batch render or two days
right there's one for each layer which
is a bit annoying i actually might get
rid of that that might just be one for
all but it'll it'll it's also quite nice
having separate renderers because they
can carry their own states and stuff
like that but maybe might be worth just
taking out the states and anyway there's
a lot of stuff that we can discuss there
but i'm not gonna bore you guys too much
so that's the directory stuff text
alignment as well so you'll see a little
that labels now have an alignment set of
options left center or right which is
really nice because what we actually had
before was and i'll just look at the
diff so i can show you guys but what we
had before is in like the in the what am
i looking for in the debug layer we used
to have all this code here on tick that
manually updated the position so you can
see that when like for example a FPS
changed because we wanted it to be right
aligned what it actually did
was when the test was set we got the
position from the FPS label and then we
updated it by getting the bounding box
of the text and then setting the
position again and it was just all it
was really annoying because again if you
wanted to have something aligned to the
right side of the screen you had to you
had to have this logic for every label
so you can see it's also for the memory
users label and for the frame time label
the labels I'm actually talking about
are the ones on the right-hand side here
so these ones these ones here at the
milliseconds the FPS in them and the
memory usage so then now all you have to
do is well you don't do that you
basically when you create the label you
specify it to be right aligned right
using this this optional parameter here
and then all you have to do is just do
that one set text you can see that
that's all I'm doing and that's it and
because it's right aligned it will know
that it's it's supposed to align it to
the right-hand side and the way that
that works internally is also pretty
simple like anytime you change the text
or the alignment the bounds will be
updated which means that it will
essentially just get the size of the
text now and then specify certain
alignment offset so it's either gonna be
size X with negative size X essentially
and then when it actually says to draw
the string it just uses that I mean
offset it's really easy it's really fast
as well and and it works really well
okay and because of that I also like
because of the whole alignment thing and
and stuff I decided to also clear up the
kind of the padding oh that's not good
I just realized that's a bit annoying so
my button is just hard-coded to be using
the debug menu and stuff okay that's
interesting I need to change that around
but but basically and it used to do that
anyway to an extent like yes
so these bounds probably just need to be
specified better but um anyway the point
is we like the debug menu and everything
I know why I closed that but the debug
menu and everything should now look kind
of prettier because it should like the
text will be like centered vertically
and everything and it's also a bit
thinner so that you can really
it needs to be even lower otherwise
we'll weapon there we won't wait to fire
or something I don't know anyway that's
very fast bring us down so yeah okay
cool anyway enough about that I think
that's about it so yeah so pretty pretty
good changes pretty solar changes just
polishing up the engine a little bit
again that optimization it was huge yeah
okay cool so let's talk about what's
next
there's also custom actions to the debug
menu now so what you can do with the
debug menu now is let's just say I'm in
sandbox so like test ready let's just go
back to test today it's a bit quick
it'll load I just say I mean here what
you can actually do and I literally
added that today was you can just
basically say debug menu and tests for
example and then what you can do is you
can pass in a lambda which does
something so for example in this case
it'll just print out the word test right
I mean if I run that and not forget that
semicolon if I run that what you'll see
is essentially an individual in the
debug menu there's now button called
tests and when I click it it will print
test right so really really simple stuff
and yeah just just a way to basically
have that running dead the reason that's
so good as well as because you can do
stuff like load levels with that now
right if you have like a level or a
different scene that you wanted to load
or a different layer or something you
can just you know put your loading like
you can basically kick off your loading
code from inside this lambda essentially
and that's it so it's really simple to
use in the backend of that is even
simpler probably come I mean if you look
at debug menu action there's now this
thing called custom action which just
takes in a function a void function and
then of course the own action is just to
call that function and
that okay cool so yeah the future let's
talk a little bit about the future so
one of the things that I'm still doing
for university is essentially I have a
set of research reports that I have to
complete and there's two of them and
what I've decided to do them and they're
like they're kind of like a Part A Part
B so they they should be linked and so
what I've decided to do for them and
they're not like particularly like
they're not research reports is in like
PhD research where it has to be like
unique or something it's just basically
just to you know it's just it's just a
research project that basically just
shows that I can do research so the
topic can be anything and what I've
decided to do is physically based
rendering which is why I've been
spending quite a while on that earlier
this year and so what I've decided to do
for Part B as well so Part A will be
kind of just physically based rendering
and what it's like how it compares to
you know other brdf some stuff like
blinn-phong and the previous kind of set
of approaches versus physically based
rendering on a modern kind of desktop
platforms like Windows for example
that'll be kind of part a of the report
and then Part B is going to be what I
decided Part B is going to be is kind of
the viability of PBR and where it's out
on mobile okay
so specifically iOS and maybe Android as
well and so what that's going to involve
since I've decided to do mobile is
porting Sparky or rather adding mobile
support to Sparky okay so Sparky will
support iOS and well iOS and Android but
for now I'm gonna start kind of working
on creating an iOS build okay so that's
gonna be what I'm gonna be doing for the
next kind of few weeks I'm still kind of
tidying up the engine here and there
with stuff like this just so that it's
you know fairly stable and looks quite
nice but yeah so in the next in the next
few weeks I'm gonna definitely start on
that iOS build because of that I've
decided to do a Mac build first it
doesn't make that much sense to do a Mac
build first but I want to do a Mac build
first anyway because I want the pros
in Xcode and I want the project I want
to set up I want to basically eliminate
all the directx and opengl and windows
kind of dependencies right I want to
make sure they're all boxed up and only
going to be compiling for Windows and I
also on the on the other side kind of
want to make sure that this engine can
be compiled with clang because right now
I've only ever tested it on msec of
course which is the visual studio
compiler and that's great
but obviously for iOS I'm gonna have to
use clang for Android I'm gonna have to
use clang as well so just making sure
that it's all compatible with clang of
course iOS kind of have has Apple's
version of clang which is a little bit
different than the claim that you'll
find for Android but anyway the point is
I'm gonna put it to Mac first so
hopefully I'll be done in like a week or
so and I'll keep you guys updated with
that I might even do some live streams
and then I'm going to after map the map
builders fell it's like stable and
everything I'm gonna put it to iOS which
will probably take two to three weeks
I'm not really sure how long it's gonna
take
it's gonna require quite a bit of extra
code and stuff because mobile platforms
in general are pretty uh pretty
intensive like there's a lot of stuff
that you really need to handle so we'll
see how that goes but it should be
pretty exciting I'm gonna definitely
enjoy seeing Sparky on iOS Sparky on
Android was act was a thing almost a
year ago I did actually get it to run on
Android with about a day's worth of work
and essentially all that involved was
basically creating a native application
and I'm just you know switching out a
few of the windowing so this was back
when Sparky was a lot smaller and didn't
have directx and opengl support but it
was it was pretty easy to implement and
so I basically know the work required to
get us to work on Android but iOS is
going to be a different face altogether
and I've never actually met an iOS app
at all so this is going to be exciting I
mean suddenly I've got experience
working with iOS and stuff like so like
that from work but
myself I haven't actually done it
personally for my projects so that
should be pretty exciting that's
basically what's gonna happen over the
next few weeks
the thing that I'm really not looking
forward to is the renderer and like the
rendering code
the reason is right now we use we have
two renderers OpenGL and DirectX the
problem is that none of those are
supported by mobile platforms right i OS
supports glares right OpenGL ES which is
completely different and I mean it's
it's similar
obviously like it's not as different as
like DirectX for example but it is very
different don't get me wrong if you
think that OpenGL ES and like if you
think glass and OpenGL are the same then
you're very much mistaken and then of
course metal so I would like to write a
metal renderer but again I'm not gonna I
don't know how long that's going to take
me a while like a few weeks at least so
I don't know if that's worth kind of
allocating time for that and then on
Android of course you have glads as well
but then you also have Vulcan which is
kind of where it's heading nowadays now
there are not there there aren't many
Vulcan devices though right like iOS
supports volka is suppose metal from I
think the iPhone 5s onwards so it's
pretty like mature but whereas Vulcan is
only supported on a handful of Android
devices I actually don't even know if
like I I guess the s7 I think the galaxy
s7 and then like Nvidia shield and stuff
I'm not even sure if I use Vulcan on
Android is somewhat out in the real
world nowadays I'm not sure because like
I was using it at work before it came
out so I don't even and I haven't set up
today with with welcome since then so
I'm not really sure if it's actually out
for the public I guess it I guess it
would be like I mean on on mobile
platforms I know it's like available for
stop and stuff but I have to look into
that so the likely thing that's going to
happen is a glass renderer just because
that's supported by both platforms and
because I don't want to spend a while
working on metal because as you know to
add another graphics API it's not gonna
be a difficult as it was to write to add
DirectX
because I had to like refactor the
engine to support you know either but
you can see how much help like how much
code is in here right like there's a
fair few like there's quite a bit of
stuff and particularly the shade of
stuff is the kind of the hard parts
right I mean yeah there's a lot of stuff
all in all I'm not particularly looking
forward to this because porting to a
different platform this isn't just about
porting to a platform it's about writing
platform support for an engine right
which is going to be not so fun and it's
gonna be a really long task but that's
what's gonna happen okay and I have to
do that now not just for myself and
because I want to but because I have to
do it for universities so yes I will be
spending more time on Sparky very soon
but yeah anyway that's I'm gonna stop
rambling that is that is the way that
the cookie crumbles okay I haven't said
that in a while um I will try and do
some live streams if I end up like
working on this stuff from a Saturday
afternoon or something but apart from
that I will definitely keep you guys
updated with dev logs and if you don't
follow me on Twitter you should it's
Twitter compost at the Cherno i will
like i'll constantly tweet like progress
updates and like you know code snippets
and whatever and make sure you following
me on slack on slack or your UI in my
slack team right so slacked out the
channel comm link will be in the
description of course because slack is a
really nice place to talk about stuff
and of course I will constantly be
posting it to the Sparky channel on that
slack and you know stuff like
screenshots and whatever if you want to
follow along with the development of
that then Twitter and slack are the best
places to do that okay cool anyway
should be a pretty exciting next few
months
oh so much work I'm just I was just I'm
just thinking how much work that is
because that is a lot of work I mean if
any of you guys want to help me out then
you are certainly more than welcome to
because obviously the actual work that I
have to do is the research report the
actual implementation is just that's not
part of the report or anything so yeah
cool anyway thanks for watching guys if
you enjoyed this video please hit like
button and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye